sport un tempo lo sport non serviva il
fatto che tu corre sia una parte
all'altra per cercare di che accerti
brontosauro e poi già passi l'orto a
colpi di pietre per farti crescere due
pomodori e depressione sono le pudori
l'uomo insieme va bene colori java
bastava e avanzava per tenerti in forma
comunque anzi ti potevi pure ritenere
fortunato se riesce a mettere su due
chili con la panza le cose sono un po
cambiate da allora abbiamo un
telecomando per i b dei fast food che
condisce euro chi fa ti spari una
valangata di patatine fritte se cioè
quella fame ti mangia pure le sorprese
che secondo me sono pure meno male dei
panini stessi tra parentesi abbiamo la
macchina e computer il divano la
possibilità di ordinare a casa il
cellulare che ha delle applicazioni che
fanno tutte queste cose che ti ho appena
elencato
sì insomma meno timori e meglio è per
combattere tutto questo basta fare un
pochino di sport
esistono varie tipologie di sportivi e
la maggior parte di queste sono molto
simpatiche categoria sportivi da sempre
una banana colazione una leggera corsa
di 40 minuti per svegliarsi una mela
pranzo una corsetta di un'oretta giusto
per digerire ma così niente di che una
nutriente legata alla tazza del pater
per integrare un pochino di calorie
perse e poi a letto senza cena
il fatto che non progettano il suicidio
rimane ancora un mistero per me
categoria magnati dello sport un uomo a
colazione ogni mattina della loro vita
anzi se se ne fanno quattro eppure
meglio e allenamento estenuante da campo
di concentramento che si protrae fino
alla mattina dopo nella quale li
troveremo molto probabilmente ancora
fare pesi pronti per iniziare una nuova
giornata nella quale non lavoreranno ma
tutto solo che faranno e continuare ad
allenarsi e fare con le diete assurde
barca da urlo fico
quanto costa questa è una delle mie
categoria preferita è quella degli
intenditori e degli appassionati che
molto spesso ha dei seri problemi a
relazionarsi col sottoscritto non
veramente sarebbe bassa tipo un
barcellona la squadra ma era questo
da vendere non real moto sarebbe
mourinho mourinho cuore al mondo della
sconfitta
guarda il nuovo tool quello che gli
stringevano a questa è realmuto sarebbe
così mourinho strano numeri al nuovo 3
lascia stare in un unico precedente
la categoria pignoli sono quelli che si
comprano tutto l'armamentario che magari
pure costosissimo buttano via soldi a
palate e che poi quando stanno per
iniziare mollano istantaneamente ok per
oggi può bastare la notte bene hanno
sforzarti troppo all'inizio la categoria
videogames che sono stanchi ma sfrutta
meglio nella cava del solo farti fregare
se l'occhio sostituire
e purtroppo infine ci sono quelli come
me quelli che mangiano a letto biscotti
stanno lì a ingrassare finché non hanno
un appuntamento a quel punto si spara
una settimana di allenamento digiuno e
manco rocky balboa ci si è sottoposto
nella speranza cosi di rimediare ai
danni commessi nei mesi precedenti danni
quali non si può riparare in una
settimana